what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
you know I've been reading comic books
for a very long time and I have seen
some very crazy things over the course
of my life I've seen all kinds of things
that either never should have happened
or were totally unexpected like
something totally unexpected The
Punisher becomes a black man that was it
was funny but like it was still kind of
crazy and it was it was still kind of
weird I've seen stories where spider-man
turned into a giant spider I've seen
stories where Captain America has done
something useful I've seen all kinds of
like crazy stories and crazy situations
and in the world of comic books but
chief among the most bonkers things I've
ever seen is the Incredible Hulk
punching reality now this is bonkers
it's one of the most nuts things that
you're gonna see okay so the way this
whole thing played out I'm not really
the guys who follow the Incredible Hulk
the biggest problem the incredible Hawks
had in like the last 20 years is
basically Greg packs run like it was an
amazing run and there's no way to top it
like there's no way to do better than
Greg pack did you I know that like like
incredible hope fans are getting ready
get get mad whenever you mention like
The Incredible Hulk in like a thing that
I don't really agree with necessarily
but isn't necessarily bad they freaked
out and they're just like no you have to
like everything about the Incredible
Hulk otherwise you don't like me and
it's just like okay well then I don't
like you but but now I'm special anyway
it's kind of nuts because it's like like
okay so you had Greg pecs run right like
Planet Hulk and you had World War Hulk
and you had all that stuff that went on
oh yeah like the Incredible Hulk
after smash and and different things
like that and so what what Marvel did in
you know like immediately after the
whole after Greg pax run was finished so
basically like part of the monster Hulk
gets done like that story finishes it
wraps and then the Incredible Hulk and
and red she-hulk they just kind of go
take off run and they touch they bump
uglies which probably causes some
earthquakes and like and in the end
that's it and I that's they're basically
done so then like Jason Aaron I think
it's Jason Aaron takes over and Jason
Aaron writes a small little stint on the
Incredible Hulk it lasts like 12 issues
or something like that or a Bruce Banner
in the Incredible Hulk are separated
like they go to dr. doom and Doctor Doom
I think he creates a body it's like he
creates a body for Bruce Banner in the
or like what anyway he creates a body
for one of them and and creates like
their own mind and memories only kind of
stuff and so they're in like two
distinctly different forms I'll remember
exactly what happened we covered it on
the cot on the channel and it wasn't
really that great of a story but then
you go into mark Wade's incredible like
indestructible Hulk agent of time and
indestructible hold on yeah it was it
was okay I mean Marvel was like winding
down right like they were going into
secret war so it's like hey look don't
don't throw all your eggs in one basket
well he
credible hope just like write a story
and be done with it and then we'll worry
about the Incredible Hulk after Secret
Wars which they didn't they killed him
and so there's like you know we'll
figure out what we want to do after that
and and so basically everybody phoned it
in on the Incredible Hulk story who just
kind of disappointed anyway agents of
time came in the aftermath of age of
Ultron right so like age of Ultron
happens Wolverine travels back and
forward through time breaks the
timestream because he's an idiot and and
basically screws things up and so like
like Galactus of the main Marvel
Universe ends up in like the ultimate
universe and all these crazy things are
going on but everybody was telling
they're like Wolverine you have to stop
traveling back and forth through time
he's like but I can't help it the
narrative calls Ford and Reich admire
Brian Michael Bendis is riding this and
he doesn't really care about the
consequences of his stories he just
writes them and so so it's like okay
whatever man-- like you you do you I
don't know who Brian Michael Bendis is
but you do you you know I mean I know he
is but like Reed Richards and them don't
nobody is I was making a joke
all right don't judge me anyway so uh so
so what they do in the aftermath of all
this is shield creates a secondary group
called time which is temporary something
or other times chief anyway it's
basically like like shield itself or
like sword or any number those
organizations but this one exists to
monitor the time stream and the reason
why is because with time having been
kind of funky and and sort of like
recovering from the whole instance of
what Wolverine had done there were there
were opportunities for individuals to
travel from the future into the past and
then try to change the past and that's
what had been happening there was some
group called the Crone arcus chrono
anarchists I don't know Mark Waid could
you have picked a more ridiculous name
they ended up like jumping back into the
past and then tried like remake reality
as they saw fit and so the Incredible
Hulk was basically an agent of shield at
this point in time and so what they
ended up doing was they ended up
grabbing the Incredible Hulk and saying
like like going to another guy named
names Arco I think of what Scott's Arcos
old-school he goes back to the old
journey into mystery comics that thing
grow tails dispense whatever was back in
like 1962 he's a guy who kind of
manipulates time but he's not like
hanging the Conqueror right I mean he
kind of liked I was like oh like time
travels but he just like vanished off
the face of the world off the face of
the world one day in comics and like he
was never really seen or heard from
again
and nobody really cared cuz I mean he
was super obscure it was like when Jason
fit with Jason when um not jason
wyngarde when Trevor Fitzroy died I
whichever fits where he was gone like
nobody really cared I mean Trevor
Fitzroy was cool and he created portals
they could allow him to travel through
time and Bantam closed him but like he
was never really that relevant and so
like you haven't really seen or heard
from Trevor Fitzroy sense and like no
he misses him because he was never that
important of a character anyway so uh so
nonetheless you end up having Bruce
Banner The Incredible Hulk who's brought
in and and he's you have Zarko who's
basically like okay here's the only way
to really stop these guys is you have to
send someone in who's like in Craig
extremely like durable and can can you
know deal with like the rigors of
constant time-traveled because that's
what the new bear in mind guys when it
comes to like you know traveling through
time and comics it's all kinds of like
crazy and it fluctuates and he could
take a lot a large tool in the body so
they send the Incredible Hulk back
they're like incredible one to do it
he's like the most durable agent of
shield so we'll send him back and
literally he gets thrown all the way
back to like some point in time and then
starts working his way forward so it was
kind of like a reworking of like the
return of Bruce Wayne when when Bruce
Wayne died or when Batman died during
Final Crisis it was actually just
time-displaced because he's Batman and
DC can't afford to cancel him so instead
of him dying just like every other
person who's ever been shot with the
Omega sanction
he just gets time this place because you
know is Batman and so so he ends up so
the Incredible Hulk ends up in the past
and starts working his way forward which
is actually kind of cool because you get
to see him like interact with a lot of
these really really old characters of
Marvel Comics that had long since been
written out of continuity but had a
place you know back in the day you know
like the Wild West kid you know and all
that kind of cool stuff it was it was
cool to see you know it was it was it
was a it was a cool concept to see but
he finally ends up getting up to the
point when it's like the 1960s and Bruce
banners hit with a gamma bomb and that's
when things really begin to pop off
because when that happens the Incredible
Hulk is there at the same time that
happens and he actually like he's like
puny banner and he like kind of saves a
life of Banner to a degree any of the
Incredible Hulk himself is struck by the
same gamma bomb that turned Banner into
the Incredible Hulk and so this starts
creating like paradoxes in the
timestream right because people like
this was not supposed to happen Bruce
Banner was supposed to hit would be hit
with the gamma bomb and that's how he
becomes Incredible Hulk but that didn't
happen
The Incredible Hulk got hit with the
gamma bomb which like doubles his powers
he becomes like Hulk squared and he
looks kind of cool actually he's got
like spikes in everything he's like
doomsday but less but like really less
menacing do we say look menacing as hell
like that was the dude that was worried
about doomsday back in the nineties man
it was it was the craziest thing he's
got like bones coming out of his bad as
like knees and stuff I'm just like okay
that guy looks really badass and like
he's probably gonna kill Superman and he
did but like but still like he looked
really cool as like Hulk squared and so
that creates all kinds of different
paradoxes because Bruce Banner
immediately comes to the realization
like as he starts to think he's like
this is not how things were supposed to
happen I was pushed out of the way of
the gamma bomb but
tell that guy is me The Incredible Hulk
is basically me I'm supposed to be in
the gamma bomb the so the question
becomes how can the Incredible Hulk be
there if he never became the Incredible
Hulk and The Incredible Hulk doesn't
exist how is that how does that work
how's that supposed to happen those are
the kind of paradoxes that were created
as a result of this so banner basically
comes to the realization and saying look
like things have to be set back to
rights things have to be set back to
normal we had to kind of set things back
so that it was like the incredible never
came back here or the situation can
unfold to where I can become me
Incredible Hulk like I'm supposed to be
and so he starts like taunting Banner
right later he starts taunting Hulk and
he's like he's like hope he's like you
know who the enemy is you know who the
bad guy here is like you know who who
the who though who the main focus you
have to start like channeling your anger
and and like you know stop being so
mindless and and like bring it back into
yourself and so he does and he kind of
goes back to his normal Incredible Hulk
form and when he does like like banners
like you know who the guy is like let go
and attack him go in attacked like that
guy zharko and so the Incredible Hulk
like freaks out and an irritation of
just literally being thrown to the
timestream and like jumping back and
forth through time just like like rears
back and just like punches the
timestream like punches reality like
shattered a Timeship and everybody
freaks out there's like oh my god like
dude like The Incredible Hulk just broke
the time barrier into our reality it's
like the entire time Darius shattered
and it means that like when things get
put back to normal that things will be
reset the way they were before the
incredible everyone back in time in the
first place yes I know it's a cheap
cop-out but it is Marvel Comics so like
so like literally punches this
timestream bricks at timestream shatters
reality as a byproduct of it and
literally everything is likes likes
being stuck into this void of just like
time and reality converging in on itself
and like it is not taking like Betty
Ross like red shield who comes like
running in with a gun and she's like I
got you incredible and literally like
fishes him back into the time stream
brings him back and gets him back into
the modern day and when he does like
literally that the damage starts to
repair stuff like Tom immediately
recovers and when that happens like
everything seals back up and everything
goes back to normal the way it was
supposed to like this rift basically
like closes back up again and so it's
kind of crazy because like Betty Ross is
basically like like red she-hulk she's
basically like holding open this taut
like this hole in time had the
Incredible Hulk Parsley's she's holding
open reality and The Incredible Hulk
like climbs back through it and then
everything seals back up again it's one
of the most insane things that her safe
I have never in the history of my life
ever seen a story aside from
superboy-prime where somebody punched
reality like shattered reality and the
time barrier because
like space and time are the same thing
they're not separate so it's like like
literally the incredible punches a hole
through space and time through reality
and like jumps from the past into the
present and then just like everything
goes back to normal and it's like well
why the hell's anybody or any time
travel just you know the Incredible Hulk
you say hey Incredible Hulk man like I
got to go back like 30 minutes ago
because like I'm late for work can you
help me out he's a girl Hulk smash like
punches a hole in the reality barrier
you know and like the time series like
there you go bro hope hope happy to help
and it's like thanks folks man you a bro
you know a like or like something like
that but let me know what you guys think
that in the comment section it's crazy
the kind of things that Incredibles done
over the years and that's not even the
first time he ever did it either like he
actually broke time once before
oh that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comment explain make sure
you guys at the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]